YOU BACK HERE MONDAY.
HAVE A GREAT WEEKEND, EVERYBODY.
>> Tucker: THIS IS A FOX NEWS
ALERT.
JUST IN THE MOMENTS AGO, BIG
CHANGES COULD BE COMING TO U.S.
POLICY FOR THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION.
THE WIDELY DISCREDITED WORLD
HEALTH ORGANIZATION.
GOOD EVENING AND WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
DOCUMENT SUGGESTS THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION WILL SOON
ANNOUNCE A MAJOR CHANGE IN
AMERICA’S POSTURE TOWARD W.H.O.
WE WILL HAVE DETAILS FOR YOU,
SORTING THROUGH THEM RIGHT NOW
AND JUST A MOMENT.
BUT FIRST, THE COUNTRY APPEARS
TO BE SPLITTING INTO TWO
HEMISPHERES EVEN AS WE WATCH.
PLACES WHERE PUBLIC OFFICIALS
ARE ALLOWING THE SCIENCE TO
GUIDE THEIR DECISIONS, STATES
LIKE THAT ARE CAUTIOUSLY
BEGINNING TO RELAX THEIR
LOCKDOWN AND FINDING NO SPIKE IN
ILLNESS AS THEY DO IT.
THEN THERE IS THE OTHER HALF OF
THE COUNTRY, PLACES YOU ARE GLAD
YOU DON’T LIVE RIGHT NOW.
IN THOSE PLACES, POWER DRUNK
POLITICIANS CROW ABOUT SCIENCE
BUT RESOLUTELY IGNORE ITS
FINDINGS AND THEY DON’T CARE
WHAT THE DATA SAYS BARED THEIR
DECISIONS ARE DRIVEN BY
AMBITION, POLITICAL CALCULATION,
AND THE PURE ANIMAL JOY OF
CONTROLLING OTHER PEOPLE’S
LIVES.
PLACES LIKE THAT ARE TIGHTENING
THEIR LOCKDOWN’S EVEN NOW.
MAY BE NO PLACE IN THE COUNTRY
REPRESENTS THE AUTHORITARIAN
APPROACH MORE STARKLY THAN
LOS ANGELES DOES.
L.A. COUNTY HAS MORE RESIDENTS
THAN NEW YORK CITY BUT WHILE
NEW YORK HAS HAD CLOSE TO
200,000 CONFIRMED CASES OF
CORONAVIRUS, L.A. HAS HAD ONLY
ABOUT 35,000 IN THE WHOLE
COUNTY.
THE REAL FIGURES ARE CERTAINLY
MUCH HIGHER THAN THAT AND THAT’S
WHAT WE FIND EVERY TIME BUT
THAT’S THE POINT, SO FEW PEOPLE
IN L.A. HAVE DIED RELATIVELY
SPEAKING THAT WE ARE NOT CERTAIN
HOW MANY ARE INFECTED.
THEY ARE NOT SICK ENOUGH TO
CROWD HOSPITALS, THE CITY’S
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM HAS NEVER
COME CLOSE TO COLLAPSING.
IN LOS ANGELES, THE CURVE IS NOW
FLAT, AND IT HAS BEEN FOR WEEKS.
COULD REOPEN TOMORROW AND IT
SHOULD REOPEN, AND IT WOULD IF
ITS LEADERS WERE FOLLOWING THE
SCIENCE.
BUT IS NOT REOPENING, JUST THE
OPPOSITE IS HAPPENING.
EVERETT GARCETTI HAS NOW
EXTENDED THE LOCKDOWN THROUGH
THE END OF JULY, TWO AND A HALF
MORE MONTHS OF IT.
LAW ENFORCEMENT LIBERALLY TO
MAKE SURE HIS CITIZENS OBEY HIS
ORDERS.
A POLICE SAY BROUGHT CRIMINAL
CHARGES AGAINST AT LEAST ASK THE
NONESSENTIAL BUSINESSES FOR THE
CRIME OF GOING TO WORK.
IN COUNTLESS OTHER BUSINESSES
HAVE SHUT FOREVER AND ARE NOT
COMING BACK.
THE CITIZENS WHO REMAIN STUCK IN
LOS ANGELES ARE EFFECTIVELY
HOSTAGES OF THE MAYOR.
HIS DEMAND THAT ANYONE THAT GOES
OUTSIDE FOR ANY REASON AS THE
HEAT RISES IN L.A. MUST WEAR A
MASK.
GOES WITHOUT SAYING THERE IS NO
SCIENCE TO BACK UP THIS ORDER OR
ANY OF HIS SO-CALLED HEALTH
DECISIONS.
IN FACT, IT’S POSSIBLE THAT
REQUIRING MASS THAT SIDE WILL
NOT PREVENT A SINGLE PERSON FROM
BEING INFECTED IN LOS ANGELES.
HE DOESN’T CARE.
ANYONE WHO DISOBEYS THIS ORDER
WILL BE PUNISHED.
IT IS JUST THE BEGINNING OF HIS
THE REALLY BIZARRE RESTRICTIONS.
THE MORE YOU KNOW, THE WEIRDER
IT IS.
WATCH, FOR EXAMPLE, AS HE
EXPLAINS ANYONE WHO GOES TO THE
BEACH MUST MAKE CERTAIN NOT TO
TOUCH DRY SAND.
WET SAND IS FINE, DRY SAND IS
NOW ILLEGAL.
>> BEACHES WILL OPEN UP THIS
WEEK FOR EXERCISE AND ACTIVE
RECREATION ONLY IN THE WET SAND
I GUESS IS A GOOD WAY OF
THINKING ABOUT IT, NOT HANGING
OUT IN TANNING IN THE DRY SAND.
>> Tucker: WHAT IS THE SCIENCE
BEHIND THIS?
ONCE AGAIN, THERE IS NONE.
THIS ISN’T A REASONED THOUGHTFUL
POLICYMAKING.
IS THE EXPRESSION OF AN AUTOCRAT
WHO DECIDED HE MUST LOOK TOUGH
BY DOING SOMETHING OR HE WON’T
GET ELECTED WHICH IS ALWAYS BEEN
HIS PRIMARY GOAL.
IS SCARY IF YOU THINK ABOUT WHAT
THIS MEANS.
A HIT MEANS THAT AMERICA’S
SECOND LARGEST CITY HAS FALLEN
UNDER THE TOTAL CONTROL OF A
NEUROTIC MEGALOMANIAC WHO IS
TERRIFIED OF DRY SAND.
HIS PERSONAL PHOBIAS ARE NOW
LOGGED IN LOS ANGELES.
MAKES YOU THINK OF THE FINAL
DAYS IN ROMANIA RANTING AT HIS
SUBJECTS FROM THE PODIUM
IMPOSING HIS STRANGE OBSESSIONS
ON THE HELPLESS POPULATION.
AS NO SURPRISE HE’S A COMPULSIVE
HAND WASHER WITH A VERY STRANGE
PERSONAL LIFE.
GUYS LIKE THIS ARE ALWAYS THE
SAME ONCE YOU SCRATCH THE
SURFACE.
SO HOW LONG WILL THEY HAVE TO
LIVE LIKE THIS?
POSSIBLY FOREVER, HE ANNOUNCED
THIS WEEK.
>> WE’VE NEVER BEEN FULLY
CLOSED, WILL NEVER BE COMPLETELY
OPEN UNTIL WE HAVE A CURE, BUT I
DO BELIEVE WE CAN TAKE STEPS,
BUT MONITOR THOSE NUMBERS,
LISTEN TO THE SCIENTISTS IN THE
MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS AND MAKE
THE TOUGH CALLS EVEN WHEN
THERE’S CRITICISM.
>> Tucker: THIS CAN’T GO ON,
IT IS TOO CRAZY.
YOU MAY MOCK LOS ANGELES AND IN
SOME CASES, IT IS DESERVED, SOME
FLAKY PEOPLE THAT LIVE THERE,
BUT THERE ARE ALSO, ALSO A LOT
OF DECENT PEOPLE IN LOS ANGELES,
MILLIONS OF THEM.
SOME OF THEM UNDERSTAND WHERE HE
IS TAKING THEM AND THEIR CITY
AND THEY’VE HAD ENOUGH.
A COUPLE OF DAYS AGO, A GROUP OF
THEM CAME TOGETHER.
IT’S TOTALLY BIPARTISAN, SOME OF
THEM WELL-KNOWN LIBERAL
DEMOCRATS AND SOME ARE CONCERNED
REPUBLICANS AND HAVE BEEN ALL
THEIR LIVES.
OTHERS ARE MIDDLE-CLASS VOTERS
BUT ONE THING THEY ALL HAVE IN
COMMON IS THE DEAD CERTAIN
KNOWLEDGE THAT HE IS POISON
HURTING THEIR CITY AND THEIR
FAMILY.
ALLOWING THEM TO LIVE ON
LOS ANGELES SIDEWALKS THAT ARE
OVER PACKED AND IF YOU’VE BEEN
THERE RECENTLY, YOU KNOW.
ALSO TOLERATED FLAGRANT
CORRUPTION IN HIS OWN
ADMINISTRATION.
NOW HE HAS SHUT THE ENTIRE CITY
DOWN SIMPLY BECAUSE HE FEELS
LIKE IT.
THIS GROUP OF CITIZENS IS GOING
TO TRY AND BOUNCE EVERETT
GARCETTI FROM THE MAYOR’S
OFFICE, AND THEY CAN.
AND POLITICIANS CAN BE RECALLED
BY VOTERS.
HE REMEMBER THAT CALIFORNIA
STATED TO THEIR GOVERNOR 17
YEARS AGO AND IT WORKED.
I RECALL PETITION REQUIRES
330,000 SIGNATURES, AND THAT
UNFORTUNATELY IS WHERE EVERETT
GARCETTI HAS THE ADVANTAGE.
THANKS TO HIS EXTENDED
SHELTER-IN-PLACE ORDERS,
CITIZENS ARE NOT ALLOWED TO
GATHER THE SIGNATURES.
SO THE GUISE OF PUBLIC HEALTH,
HE HAS STOPPED HIS POLITICAL
OPPONENTS FROM OPPOSING HIM.
AND HE IS NOT THE ONLY ONE.
YOU SEE THIS HAPPEN IN MICHIGAN,
NEW JERSEY, OTHERS.
POLITICIANS AROUND THE COUNTRY
ARE DOING THIS.
AS LONG AS THERE IS NO VACCINE
FOR THE WUHAN CORONAVIRUS, THEY
CAN REMAIN IN POWER UNCHALLENGED
FOREVER.
IT’S NICE FOR THEM.
THEY WERE ENJOYING IT.
BUT IN LOS ANGELES, HE MAY HAVE
GONE TOO FAR.
THE FUTURE OF THE CITY IS AT
STAKE.
THE RECALL HE FORCES ARE TAKING
THIS ISSUE TO COURT TRYING TO
WIN THE RIGHT TO GATHER THE
SIGNATURES ONLINE.
IT’S IMPORTANT.
BUT THE BIGGER POINT IS, THESE
PEOPLE ARE NOT PASSIVE.
THESE ARE AMERICANS WHO
UNDERSTAND WHAT HAS BEEN TAKEN
FROM THEM, AND THEY ARE TRYING
TO GET IT BACK AS THEY SHOULD.
WE ARE SEEING THIS HAPPEN AROUND
THE COUNTRY.
IN NEW JERSEY FOR EXAMPLE,
CITIZENS ARE STILL BANNED FROM
ASSEMBLING TO WORSHIP TOGETHER
AS THEY CHOOSE.
THAT’S A DIRECT VIOLATION OF THE
FIRST AMENDMENT OF THE
U.S. CONSTITUTION.
WE ASKED THE GOVERNOR ABOUT THIS
WHEN HE CAME ON OUR SHOW AND
SAID HE WASN’T EVEN THINKING